[music playing]
- All right, the packages now.
Whoo, there's supposed
to be a tire here.
- All right.
- All the packages
seem to be the same.
Based off my experience,
I believe it's
meth, just from how it feels.
It's crunchy.
I don't have a smell.
You can see the meth here,
so I got lucky this time.
Next, I'm going to
move it into our SEC,
which is our contraband
center, and get our drugs out.
[door opens]
[trunk opens]
Drugs, count 1--
[clattering]
--27 28, 29, 30.
30 sounds like a healthy number.
So from this point, going to
take my drugs in, and then
I'm going to get them tested.
[trunk closes]
[wheels rattling]
All right.
- And my weight?
- Thank you.
So got it all on there, 30
packages of methamphetamine,
approximately 14.4 kilograms.
Next, I'm going to get an agent
from HSI to take over the case,
place the subject under arrest.
And then the drugs
are ultimately
going to be destroyed and
burned at one of our facilities.
[music playing]